A traditional Chinese instrument gets the rock star treatment...
...and thousands of hits on YouTube.
I'm Jen Markham on Buzz60.
The Guzheng is a stringed instrument that's been around since ancient times...
...and is most commonly associated with traditional Chinese music like this.
But Vancouver Guzheng player...
...Michelle Kwan has taken the instrument from the 8th century to 1988.
Outfitting her Guzheng with an amp and distortion pedal,...
...tying on an Axl Rose style bandana,...
...and just shredding a cover of Guns N' Roses, Sweet Child of Mine.
The video is racking up thousands of hits on YouTube...
...with hundreds leaving comments of praise,...
...including current Guns N' Roses guitarist Bumblefoot,...
...and many others making a request for additional covers.
Here's hoping she responds.
How awesome would some Zeppelin be next.
Buzz60, now you know, pass it on.